bougez pas dans la jungle il a dit ça on
va pas bouger
on ne bouge pas pendant une heure
non mais yop affecte non non vous pouvez
venir quand vous voulez parce que vous
ne bougez pas pendant le jingle j te
regarde ici monsieur oui ça avec nos
amis il faut le savoir quand elle
rencontre un homme pour la première fois
il faut la regarder dans les yeux sinon
c'est même pas la peine de la garderie
mais nous on se connaissait depuis
longtemps et je regardais ses pieds moi
qu'est ce que vous pensez des caisses
alors philippe geluck vous connaissez le
portrait chinois
oui le portrait chinois c'est si tu
étais une fleur quelles fleurs serais-tu
bon l'an petit portrait chinois c'est
plus compliqué si vous étiez une injure
ce serait gros cons ah oui parce que
gros con c'est vraiment bien parce que
pour être un gros con il faut pas être
gros ouais il suffit d'être con ça
al'avantage ça fait un bon match
belinda vous suivez là en tout à fait on
l'a commandé gros qu en anglais alors
est bon se poser la question précisément
mais on s'est dit texto kate moss a jugé
jean maladie la maladie de parkinson
parce que ça me permettrait de continuer
à jouer des maracas et puis désigné pour
le trouver si vous étiez un accident en
art on part d'accidents heureux un
peintre dans le pinceau dérape crée
parfois une tâche magnifique mais vous
étiez une perversion
je crois que je suis une perversion une
guerre un coin un conflit nucléaire
mondial ça résoudrait pas mal de
problèmes sur le réchauffement de la
terre à se régler au moins je vous étiez
indices le vis sans fin ses ventes et
par michel-ange une trahison
salut je suis quelqu'un de fidèle en
amitié dans le travail et dans la vie ce
serait peut-être de vous révéler des
secrets touchant michel drucker a
michel drucker et son chien oui parce
que je les vois parfois dans le bureau
et je sais qu'il prend les véritables
décisions si vous étiez vous étiez une
norme un canon j'ai toujours rêvé d'être
un canon de la bleue en face d'eux mais
oui il dit flight en transmettent une
fille est très jolie on dit c'est un
canon un canon belinsky merci oui bien
sûr si je tourne à une cicatrice si vous
êtes une cicatrice le sourire
ouais une cicatrice qui ne se referment
jamais à la la c'est bon ça y est c'est
bon mais il est trop fort soutien [ __ ]
vous
c'est rare que je sois si vous était un
dictateur
vous pouvez pas dire vous l'avez dit une
fois le maître du monde
ouais oui parce que je fais pas les
choses à moitié
oui donc maîtres du monde ou rien maître
du monde aurélien si vous étiez une
infirmité la calvitie
oui parce que c'est celle infirmité qui
a des avantages de même ce n'est pas
douloureux
oui c'est vrai ça fait gagner du temps
le matin pour se coiffer et puis ça rend
tellement séduisant et c'est vrai baboo
en tous les cas ce serait vachement
gaffe a permis à l'homme chauve ça vous
ça vous fait fuir
non ça me fait rire faire est
complètement chauve et ben voilà johnny
campbell le grand père et donc il ne va
pas donc à la glisse est ce qu'il veut
dans son chapeau et quand j'avais 4 ans
aéroports il a je lui enlever son
chapeau il était sûr très noir si vous
étiez un microbe la grippe vous vous
tombez vous êtes microbes et vous avez
la possibilité de donner la grippe
je sais pas au chanteur carlos ou à
naomi campbell
vous hésitez pasà oui ah bah non clair
vous connaissez carlos dias heures
si vous étiez nasa regard si vous étiez
un terroriste carlos
vous êtes c'est une torture une torture
oui tantôt india oui c'est vrai que ça
ramollit les cours il est con il s'est
bien ajusté et la torture soit rapide si
vous étiez une humiliation comme un coin
à paris v a attiré ce que l'humiliation
réponse en même temps et si vous étiez
mort la petite mort à bout mais bon si
formidable humble merci beaucoup merci
de global